so now we've got the full spectrum here
we can create objects move them and see
them sliding around the world which is
great because now we can actually throw
missiles from one robot at another the
final missing piece however to our grand
scheme of world domination is what to do
once the missile hits the other robot
now in our current setup we receive no
information that a collision has
occurred but we only get back the
position of the objects that the physics
engine has adjusted but fret not my
children there is a solution we're going
to need to jump around between a few
different files and concepts but once
we're done you'll be able to allow each
entity to respond to a collision
independent of other entities now the
start of this nice aside is a box2d
function that allows us to define an on
collision callback that when called is
given to physics bodies that are
touching